[Musik]
die einen hat es mir zufällig hier
verschlagen
[Musik]
dies sei überwältigend statt das von
peter straßen zusammen
und bin fast überfahren worden michael
brücker gewann tasche chris
[Musik]
andere flüchteten aus der zu engen
heimat
und ich nutze eine frau ganz oben am
vierten stocks ganze meine bescheidene
studio monik
[Musik]
die meisten wollen sich in new york
verwirklichen
wieder draußen von sigurd erfolg
[Musik]
und ich habe die letzten drei jahre als
korrespondent in inmitten von jonathan
gelebt hier verdichte stress ein
fremdwort ist die wahrheit auf der
straße liegt und wo strom und wasser
während hurricanes seien die zwei wochen
lang ausgefallen waren
ich sage new york und denke kalkutta
wäre es hier schafft schafft es überall
warum aber wollen wir es überhaupt in
new york schaffen
und was macht diese stadt mit uns davon
erzählt dieser film
[Musik]
eine immigrantin aus der schweiz
dabei kennt gabriela das viertel
williamsburg in brooklyn gut
[Musik]
schon zum dritten mal wandert sie hier
ein neuer so schaut es hin und her wenn
es amerika und russland auf hotel
fachangestellte wie gabriele haben die
usa nicht gewartet bisher war es ein
rein und raus mit einjährigen visa
jetzt aber wurde sie ausgelost für ein
drei jahres wie so gabriela die
glückliche träumt den amerikanischen
traum von der geschäftsführerin eines
batterie factory in bayern zur
restaurant managerin in new york
unterdessen an der noblen upper east
side ist es relativ einfach die usa
andere
damals war das land noch auf immigranten
angewiesen
nicht nur die einwanderung war damals
ein kinderspiel und der park avenue
kaufte rosa 34.000 dollar eine wohnung
zusammen mit ihrem verstorbenen ehemann
heute ist eine solche wohnung rund eine
million wert
garbe jenes wege kollegin stammt aus
südkorea leben auf engstem raum
im gegensatz zu gabriel wollte rosa
nicht unbedingt in die usa
rosa wollte vor allem aus der schweiz
der schweizer muss landeka rote hand und
automatisch ihre schweizer bürgerrechts
verlor der spanier keine machen
da nicht sofort panik ein schweizer
banker haben iranische berufen als
bewilligung wie eines längeren
aufenthalts bewilligung
das ist furchtbar and chicks
um das sie ihr bürgerrecht später für
zehn franken zurückkaufen konnte aber
die sache auch nicht wirklich besser
gemacht
prosa heute eine eingebürgerte und
überzeugte amerikanerin
[Musik]
beim und daunen und man weiß überhaupt
nicht was einmal behauptet
mein weg die eigene grenze kann alle
ihre und der überschritten oder über
wegen der angst überwindet performance
künstlerin karina bachelor am tag nach
der maturafeier reiste die heute
44-jährige ab nach new york und blieb
eigentlich zufällig und doch nicht new
york scheint so etwas wie eine therapie
für sie gewesen zu sein weg von der
engen heimat weg von der familie
schwierig seien inzwischen sehr
turbulent xx sie in brück semi hand
eigentlich lösen und uns ist sehr sehr
herzlich sie und schauen sich damit
selbst uhr hatte sich einfach eine neue
erfahrung machen und ich habe was für
ein unterschied zu hause wo man dazu
erzogen werden die nachbarn nicht zu
stören und war sogar die farbe ihres
lippenstifts kommentiert worden sein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
carina sagt erst in new york habe sie
sich getraut zu singen und kunst zu
machen
das geht aber nur für die sie sich
leisten können denn nirgendwo in den usa
sind die gegensätze zwischen arm und
reich größer als in new york um die 86
jährige rosa legt diese gegensätze ein
paar mal im jahr
übernachtet die reiche pensionärin von
der opfer ist bei den ärmsten der stadt
und sie tut es ehrenamtlich
freiwilligenarbeit wird hochgeschrieben
in den usa wo fürsorge praktisch nicht
existiert und europa als sozialistisch
geht
was muss saniert werden immer mehr oder
wenig ist nachgelegt vom nabu filme als
wenn du einfach ideen eigentlich reichen
es geht also um die herausforderung um
die chance sich persönlich zu entwickeln
als preis dafür lebt die 30 jährige
gabriela wieder wie zu lehrlings zeiten
new york testet unsere grenzen die
meisten sind wenn er entweder auf oder
unter wasser so verdienen ja gar nicht
was das ist ja 52 stunden
[Musik]
eigentlich wurde gabriel als
geschäftsführerin eines neuen
restaurants in brooklyn angestellt nun
aber verzögern sich die bewilligungen
darum wurde sie von ihrem schweizer chef
in ein anderes lokal versetzt
jetzt will das projekt im land des hire
and fire der kündigung von einem tag auf
den anderen nichts außergewöhnliches wie
heißt zwischen gabriela trägt die volle
verantwortung sagt ihr vorgänger den job
geschmissen hat
[Musik]
das priorat das büro oberhalb des
restaurants liegt in einem wohnhaus
heikel ist vor allem die eingebaute
großküche die eigentliche küche im lokal
sei zu klein
typisch new york denke ich wo die
gesetze nicht immer klar sind und jeder
die schlupflöcher nutzen die sich bieten
gabi ist hier mädchen für alles
undenkbar für eine geschäftsführerin in
der schweiz
zudem verdient sie monatlich rund 2000
franken weniger aber die tellerwäscher
karriere hat noch nie oben begonnen
[Musik]
chefkoch franzi ein franzose
ausgezeichnet mit einem michelin stern
erhält für hier aus reinem goodwill aus
[Gelächter]
ja dann bin eigentlich dachten wir
new york seine leistungsgesellschaft
aber in den leiden wird vor allem
improvisiert effizienz sucht man
anderswo
[Musik]
es fühlt sich auf weniger verantwortlich
sind antworten sie nach ihrer scout
machen oder es gaben auch handelte war
zu groß
auch in clariness wohnquartier urbanes
in brooklyn
früher war das viertel verpönt wegen der
schwerindustrie
jetzt aber ist die gentrifizierung in
vollem gang überall sanierungen und
neubauten auch die gelernte bildhauerin
hat ihr haus renoviert
ich komme in new york sondern will die
stadt ist wirklich weißt du selber aus
das muss ständig ein und nicht nur eines
auch das haus hinter dem garten gehört
clarin dafür fragen nicht so erfolgreich
als künstlerin dass sie das alles
verschleißt bin finde ich sehr
erfolgreich als künstlerin will ich bin
sehr glücklich und mit dem wasserhahn
aber ich meine finanzielle last ist es
natürlich sehr schwierig mit mit kunst
sowie geld verdienen
über ihre finanziellen verhältnisse aber
wie carina keine auskunft geben
das funktioniert so man opel user wunsch
bis in andere man schuhe auf seriöse
sportfernsehen und ich tue gern
filmleute aus einer fernseh sich finden
clariness skulptur krebsgeschwür oder
gebärmutter new york habe sie gelehrt
dass alles relativ ist
genau das haben wir doch das einzige was
sie an ihre wahlheimat störe sei die
politik der amerikaner hunter rassismus
noch nicht überwunden
die polizisten die maximale film gleich
im nachtbus von profitieren die firmen
allesamt winkel medien und das natürlich
ganz schlimm und dann duschen eine
uniform alicke und dein herz gefühls
hier
das image der new yorker polizei ist
angeschlagen weil beamte zwei
unbewaffneten schwarzen erschossen haben
mittendrin die 86 jährige rosa seit über
30 jahren ehrenamtliche hilfspolizisten
[Musik]
rosa ist nervös heute ist die beerdigung
von zwei erschossenen polizisten ein
racheakt für die schwarzen wurde
ehrensache dass hilfspolizist in
schupbach teilnimmt bei der new yorker
polizei werde sie auch aus seniorin noch
gebraucht in der schweiz würde man sie
doch bloß auslachen
heute ist mal wieder ein tag an dem ihr
das leben wir wie ein hollywood film
erscheint sogar die klavier zum
spektakel zeigen unsere handschlag sie
seien stolz zur new yorker polizei zu
gehören zur polizei gewalt und rassismus
äußere sie sich darum nicht rosa sagt
was so viele amerikaner sagen
die usa seien das beste land der welt
das land hat mich mit offenen armen
empfangen und für gas bis ich dankbar
das land der freiheit ich denke an meine
beiträge über die todesstrafe über das
gefangenenlager guantanamo über obamas
krieg gegen den terror mit unbemannten
drohnen an große große problem als
auslandschweizer wird wo mehr als
kriminelle behandelt
die amerikaner und wir ihren freund
miles hat carina im supermarkt
kennengelernt
aber wie mir war es ihr in den ersten
jahren schwer gefallen amerikanische
freunde zu finden
unsere kulturen seien verschieden wahr
wir schweizer eine viel ältere
geschichte haben quasi die bürger
derzeit auf uns tragen tisches jungs
folgte sind als erste 200 jahre da und
sie sind für ihr kind alles ausprobieren
in unserer gesellschaft ist die pop und
sport kultur das wichtigste leute sie in
diesen branchen arbeiten bekommen die
höchsten löhne
wir werden also mit dieser kultur
überschwemmt und das ist oberflächlich
[Musik]
die sprichwörtlichen klischees sie haben
halt doch viel wahres die amerikanische
unzuverlässigkeit hat auch mich immer
wieder genervt zu hause bei clarin das
cousine aber fällt es mir wie schuppen
von den augen als ich höre was die
13-jährige tochter sophie erlebt hast
das amerikanische mädchen ging letztes
jahr in der schweiz zur schule und
machte dort ihre erfahrung mit dem was
wir für schweizer tugenden halten
disziplin und perfektion antwort das ist
schweizer
mit fotostrecke mit erforschen und
wurzel an die actinote wenn sie
schlechte noten sind sie ich habe mal
eine kasse so dass ich das so schlimm
city einig sein
für mich symbolische geschichten unter
druck zur perfektion lähmt ja er kann
ein ganzes land in angst versetzen
in den usa dagegen ist versagen völlig
normal es gehört zum leben
ein gefühl das uns befreit und mutig
macht man eigentlich haben wir mit rosa
unsere mutige pionierin verkörpert die
extreme der staat sie lebe gerne
zwischen den welten sagt sie und reisst
mehrmals im jahr nach zürich in die
wohnung ihrer verstorbenen eltern aber
ihre alte heimat ist der eingebürgerten
amerikanerin fremd geworden
immerhin traum ich kann ihn nicht so
gern amerika
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und sich nicht ständig bedroht sehen
dabei etwas eingeschlafen ist es spiel
ernst und keine stadt beherrscht dieses
spiel besser aus new york
hier wo uns neben dem morbiden das
atemberaubende ins gesicht schlägt new
york hat mich gezwungen mein blick zu
weiten
diese stadt ist alles und sein gegenteil
absolute wahrheiten gibt es nicht und wo
alles im fluss ist kannst du nicht
stehen bleiben
[Musik]